[Musique]
travailleuses travailleurs
aucun des candidats qui ont une chance
d'être au deuxième tour ne propose un
programme susceptible d'apporter une
solution au chômage à la crise du
logement et à la baisse du pouvoir
d'achat qui sont les principaux maux qui
frappent toutes les classes populaires
je parle seulement d'un programme qui au
lieu de privilégier les intérêts de la
classe capitaliste rétablir est un peu
l'équilibré entre celles ci et les
travailleurs en supprimant une partie
des privilèges économiques des
propriétaires de capitaux afin
d'améliorer le sort des classes
populaires
ce que j'ai commencé à exposer depuis le
début de cette campagne serait le seul
programme possible d'une présidence qui
voudrait s'attaquer immédiatement et
efficacement à la crise du logement au
chômage massif à la dégradation du
niveau de vie de la plus grande partie
de la population bien sûr il ne s'agit
pas de ce que pourrait faire nicolas
sarkozy françois bayrou ou le pen car
chacun à leur manière ils se situent
ouvertement sur le terrain de la défense
des seuls intérêts du patronat
cependant la candidate du parti
socialiste ne propose pas mieux par
rapport à ces questions essentielles
pour la classe ouvrière
elle propose de porter le smic à 1500
euros brut d'ici cinq ans ce qui fait qu
étant donné la hausse du coût de la vie
cela ne donnera pas plus de pouvoir
d'achat elle ne propose de construire
qu'un nombre dérisoire de hlm bien en
dessous des besoins réels et rien mais
alors rien pour réduire le chômage ni
même pour l'empêcher de s'aggraver à
part de créer des emplois qui seraient
gratuits pour les patrons mais pourquoi
pancréas l'or dans les services publics
on serait certain que ce serait des
emplois utiles surtout il n'est pas
admissible que dans la france de 2007
des millions de personnes y compris des
travailleurs ayant un salaire régulier
soit mal logées voire pas du tout et
certaines contraintes de vivre dans des
taudis des immeubles délabrés des
campings ou dans la rue pourtant l'état
pourrait construire les moyens matériels
et financiers existent
1 millions de hlm par an afin en trois
ans de résorber les besoins pour mettre
fin au scandale que constitue la crise
actuelle du logement il n'est pas
admissible non plus que le chômage et
cartes des activités utiles à la
collectivité
plusieurs millions de personnes alors
que celles qui ont un emploi sont
astreints à des charges de travail de
plus en plus lourdes
un programme réellement démocratique
déciderait la possibilité du contrôle
par les travailleurs et par la
population de la comptabilité des
tailles et de toutes ces sociétés
chacun pourrait voir ce que sont
réellement les financer les transferts
d'argent de celles qui prétendent être
en difficulté et vérifier que les
suppressions d'emplois dans l'immense
majorité des cas ne sont pas la
conséquence de contraintes économiques
mais celle de la soif de profit des
propriétaires un programme réellement en
faveur de la population mettrait un coup
d'arrêt à la chute continue du niveau de
vie par le relèvement immédiat du smic à
1500 euros net et par une augmentation
uniforme de 300 euros de tous les
salaires et des pensions ainsi que le
relèvement parallèle de tous les minima
sociaux
le financement de ces mesures reposerait
sur une augmentations sélectives des
impôts qui ne toucherait que les revenus
très élevés et les bénéfices des
sociétés en particulier celles du cac 40
et de façon modérée par rapport à
l'ampleur de leurs profits il ne s'agit
même pas d'un partage des richesses il
s'agit seulement que les plus riches
participent ainsi à l'effort nécessaire
pour compenser les inégalités les plus
criantes entre les plus riches et les
plus pauvres
en deux mots ce que j'ai à dire c'est ce
que devraient être les premières mesures
d' un gouvernement vraiment socialiste
mais ce n'est pas évidemment ce que
ferait un gouvernement de droite
mais ce n'est pas non plus ce cas
l'intention de faire ségolène royal
c'est pourquoi je vous demande de voter
pour ce programme en vous servant du
bulletin à mon nom pour voter contre la
droite mais aussi pour dire à la gauche
que c'est ce programme là que vous
voulez
[Musique]